Es conocida como la nación del arco iris
por su gran diversidad de culturas, idiomas
y religiones.
Tan solo su Constitución reconoce como oficiales
ni más ni menos que ¡¡11 idiomas diferentes!!
Por supuesto hablamos de Sudáfrica, un país
que tal y como indica su nombre está situado
en el extremo sur de África.
No hablamos de un país pequeñito, su superficie
es mayor que las de Alemania, Francia, Italia,
Bélgica y los Países Bajos ¡juntas!
Sudáfrica es con diferencia la economía
más desarrollada de toda el África subsahariana
y fue en 2010, además, el primer país africano
en acoger un mundial de futbol.
Lo hizo a ritmo del “Waka waka” de Shakira
y desde luego los españoles lo tenemos muy
presente ¿Verdad?
Por primera vez ganamos la copa del mundo
gracias a ese histórico gol de Iniesta en
el descuento.
Pues bien, el mes más importante de la historia
de este país fue abril de 1994.
Entre los días 26 y 29 de dicho mes se celebraron
las primeras elecciones democráticas, libres
y universales de la historia de este país.
Sí, no me he equivocado, las elecciones duraron
4 días y durante este tiempo los sudafricanos
salieron masivamente a votar.
Las colas fueron kilométricas.
No era para menos, estás elecciones pusieron
fin a 300 años de colonialismo y supremacía
blanca.
Estas elecciones significaban el fin para
siempre del apartheid.
EL APARTHEID
El Aparteheid fue un terrible sistema de segregación
racial que estuvo en vigor durante casi 50
años.
Fundamentalmente consistía en separar a la
población blanca de la población negra,
tanto para vivir, estudiar o pasar el tiempo
libre.
Por supuesto, ya os lo podéis imaginar, todas
las mejores zonas y los mejores servicios
eran para los blancos.
Un buen ejemplo, las ambulancias.
A pesar de que los negros representaban el
80% de la población apenas tenían ambulancias.
En cambio, las ambulancias para blancos eran
numerosas, y, además, se negaban a llevar
a personas negras porque por ley podían hacerlo.
El Apartheid les otorgaba a los blancos todo
el poder político, y además, fijaba muchísimas
restricciones, precisamente, para consolidar
el poder blanco.
Por ejemplo, los matrimonios e incluso las
relaciones mixtas estaban terminantemente
prohibidas.
De facto, el apartheid relegaba a la población
negra, que era insisto la gran mayoría, a
una condición no humana.
Así había dos Sudáfricas muy distintas:
una, la negra, terriblemente pobre, y otra,
la blanca, muy rica.
Y claro, la represión y los castigos contra
quienes se rebelaban eran, por supuesto, también
terribles:
“El 16 de junio de 1976, miles de estudiantes
negros se manifestaron para pedir mejoras
sociales y educativas, y cientos de ellos
fueron masacrados”.
EL SUEÑO DE MANDELA
Pero en 1994, todo cambió, y lo hizo de la
mano del que hoy es considerado el padre de
este país, Nelson Mandela, también popularmente
conocido como Madiba.
«Siempre he atesorado el ideal de una sociedad
libre y democrática en la que las personas
puedan vivir juntas en armonía y con igualdad
de oportunidades.
Es un ideal para el que he vivido.
Es un ideal por el que espero vivir, y si
es necesario, es un ideal por el que estoy
dispuesto a morir».
Mandela fue un líder en la lucha política
contra el apartheid y el racismo, un activismo
que no le salió gratis.
En 1961 fue condenado por “traición”
a cadena perpetua.
Mandela se pasó los siguientes 27 años en
la cárcel, hasta 1992.
Y solo cuatro años más tarde, en las elecciones
de 1994, fue elegido Presidente de Sudáfrica,
el primer presidente negro del país.
Para sorpresa de muchos, su apuesta no fue
la venganza sino la reconciliación.
Mandela soñaba con una Sudáfrica libre,
unida y prospera.
Algo que dejó muy claro en su discurso de
investidura:
“Ha llegado el momento de curar las heridas.
El momento de salvar los abismos que nos dividen.
Nos ha llegado el momento de construir.
[..] Contraemos el compromiso de construir
una sociedad en la que todos los sudafricanos,
tanto negros como blancos, puedan caminar
con la cabeza alta, sin ningún miedo en el
corazón, seguros de contar con el derecho
inalienable a la dignidad humana”
A diferencia de tantos otros, Mandela cumplió
su palabra: trabajó por una Sudáfrica cohesionada
y cuando llegó el momento, con los límites
marcados en la Constitución, dejó el poder
y se hizo a un lado.
Eso le convirtió en un verdadero mito.
(Por cierto, un apunte importantísimo, amigos.
Cuando hablamos de un país nunca jamás pretendemos
desprestigiarlo, todo lo contrario.
Los que nos seguís desde hace tiempo sabéis
que nos gusta viajar, conocer diferentes culturas
y que soñamos con un mundo más abierto y
con menos barreras.
Digo todo esto porque cuando recientemente
publicamos el vídeo en el que denunciamos
la terrible situación por la que atraviesa
El Salvador, algunos de vosotros nos escribisteis
diciéndonos que a lo mejor esto podía ser
malo para el país.
No lo creemos en absoluto.
El Salvador es una bellísima tierra, pero
ahora mismo atraviesa un momento difícil,
eso es una realidad.
En VisualPolitik estamos convencidos de que,
para poder ser resuelto, el problema tiene
que conocerse y denunciarse, a nivel local
e internacional
De todas formas, también lo sabéis, aunque
somos optimistas con el mundo en que vivimos,
publicamos vídeos con diferentes enfoques,
algunos son positivos y otros negativos, porque…
en la vida no todo es color de rosas)
Pero, volvamos a Sudáfrica, el único país
del mundo que no tiene una sola capital, sino
que tiene tres:
Ciudad del Cabo, la capital del poder legislativo;
Pretoria, la del poder Ejecutivo y Bloemfontein,
la del poder judicial.
Y por si fuese poco, amigos, la ciudad más
grande y donde se concentran los negocios,
no es ninguna de las tres, sino una cuarta,
Johannesburgo.
Así que sí, que no os extrañe que ni siquiera
los libros de texto de los colegios se pongan
nunca de acuerdo.
Pues bien, tras la caída del régimen del
Apartheid, Sudáfrica vivió un despegue notable.
Desde 1994 el tamaño de la economía real,
teniendo en cuenta la capacidad de compra,
se ha triplicado,
https://www.google.es/publicdata/explore?ds=d5bncppjof8f9_&met_y=ny_gdp_mktp_cd&idim=country:ZAF:NGA&hl=es&dl=es#!ctype=l&strail=false&bcs=d&nselm=h&met_y=ny_gnp_mktp_pp_cd&scale_y=lin&ind_y=false&rdim=region&idim=country:ZAF:NGA&ifdim=region&hl=es&dl=es&ind=false
la pobreza se ha reducido con mucha fuerza
y cientos de miles de familias negras se integran
cada año en la clase media.
La violencia, aunque sigue siendo muy alta,
porque Sudáfrica es un país peligroso, se
ha reducido.
Y en general el acceso al agua potable, la
electricidad o la sanidad también han mejorado
muchísimo.
Por poner casos: Sudáfrica es la gran potencia
turística y también financiera del África
Subsahariana.
Tiene la mayor bolsa de todo el continente
e incluso, ojo, es una potencia de la industria
automovilística.
Empresas como Volswagen, BMW, Nissan, General
Motors, Ford, Mercedes o Toyota tienen aquí
fábricas de montaje.
Suena todo bien ¿Verdad?
Pues desgraciadamente las cosas hoy no pintan
tan bien.
CRISIS Y ESTANCAMIENTO
A pesar de todos los logros cosechados, la
economía sudafricana lleva prácticamente
estancada desde 2009:
la economía no crece, el desempleo es de
los más altos del mundo, y en general trabaja
muy poquita gente.
Fijaros, el país tiene unos 55 millones de
habitantes; pero solo 15 tienen trabajo, y
muchos de ellos, encima, trabajos informales.
Además, la inversión de las empresas lleva
cayendo 9 años, su moneda el RAND se ha devaluado
muchísimo y la deuda pública está a punto
de ser declarada como bonos basura.
Vamos, ¡un desastre!
De hecho, en los últimos años, las rentas
más altas están literalmente escapando del
país.
Pero claro, os preguntareis ¿Qué diantres
ha ocurrido?
JACOB ZUMA
Jacob Zuma es el Presidente desde 2009 y su
mandato ha sido ¿Cómo decirlo?: desastroso.
Solo para que os hagáis una idea, este señor
se enfrenta ante la justicia, atentos, a 783
casos de corrupción.
Vamos, todo un profesional a la hora de meter
la mano.
Pero no solo eso, el señor Zuma ha apostado
por políticas que dificultan la inversión
extranjera, por ejemplo, favoreciendo legalmente
las expropiaciones, que ha hecho por ley,
más fáciles y más baratas.
Por cierto, esto que está sonando nos lo
ha mandado Happy Creeps, un grupo formado
por unos estudiantes de Ciencias Políticas
de la Universidad Pablo Olavide de Sevilla.
Si tienes un grupo de música y quieres que
aparezca en el canal, te dejamos la información
de cómo hacerlo en la descripción.
Pero volviendo a Sudáfrica.
El Presidente Jacob Zuma también, ha convertido
la regulación laboral en una traba casi insalvable
para la contratación.
Precisamente, su última medida ha sido subir
muchísimo el salario mínimo:
¡En un país donde no poca gente trabaja!
Así son muchos los analistas que critican
la medida diciendo que es un disparate fijar
un salario mínimo superior al salario de
casi la mitad de los trabajadores….
Vamos a ver, todos queremos que los salarios
suban, pero para lograrlo habrá que generar
primero la riqueza ¿no os parece?
Si no se genera empleo con salarios mucho
más bajos imaginaros ahora…
Los problemas de Sudáfrica son otros.
Y entre ellos destaca con fuerza su horrible
sistema educativo.
El DESASTROSO SISTEMA EDUCATIVO
El sistema educativo de Sudáfrica es malísimo:
1 de cada 3 estudiantes que han ido a la escuela
durante 6 años tiene problemas para leer
y solo 1 de cada 100 estudiantes negros logra
hacer una ingeniería.
Todo esto es un problema, porque afecta al
emprendimiento y porque las empresas tienen
dificultades para encontrar mano de obra cualificada.
Y no es una cuestión de dinero, Sudáfrica
es uno de los países que relativamente más
invierte en educación.
Entonces ¿Qué ocurre?
Pues muchos dicen que la culpa está en que
el Sindicato de Docentes Demócratas, que
controla el sistema público se ha convertido
en una verdadera mafia.
El sindicato es aliado del Presidente Zuma
y además de terminar con las inspecciones
educativas ha enchufado a tanta gente que
hoy la formación de los profesores está
por los suelos.
Hace unos años se hizo un test a los profesores
de matemáticas de niños de 11 y 12 años.
Pues bien, el resultado fue que 8 de cada
10 profesores obtuvieron un resultado peor
que el que se esperaba de sus alumnos…
¡Como para enseñar!
Por supuesto, los resultados para los blancos,
que van a colegios privados, son bastante
diferentes.
Hay herencias del apartheid que aún no se
han superado.
CONFLICTO RACIAL
Por si fuese poco en los últimos años se
están recrudeciendo los enfrentamientos raciales.
En 2013 se creó el partido Combatientes de
la Libertad Económica que hoy ya es la tercera
fuerza política del país.
Miembros de este partido radical defienden
casi invertir lo que era el apartheid y aplicárselo
a los blancos
“No estamos pidiendo la masacre de los blancos,
al menos por ahora” Julius Malema, líder
de Combatientes de la Libertad Económica.
Su fuerza aun es pequeña, pero como elemento
de desestabilización, os podéis imaginar…
En fin, hoy por hoy, podemos decir que el
sueño de Nelson Mandela corre peligro.
Bueno, tú qué opinas ¿Conseguirá Sudáfrica
hacer realidad el sueño de Madiba?
¿Podrá Sudáfrica volver a ser la nación
más próspera y libre de toda África?
¿O tal vez por el contrario el odio, la desconfianza
y las malas políticas harán de este país
poco más que un sueño pasajero?
Espero vuestras respuestas, y si este vídeo
os ha resultado interesante y queréis que
hablemos más de África no olvidéis darle
a like y por supuesto suscribiros al canal
para recibir nuestros nuevos vídeos.
Por cierto, si queréis descubrir cómo está
cambiando este continente no os podéis perder
este vídeo.
(¿Será África la nueva china?
Un saludo y hasta la próxima